These are questions that I got from the
Center For The Future Museums.
They say for readers who
may be unfamiliar with
Khan Academy, can you
give a capsule description
of your work? I'll make
it even clear. It's just
not my work anymore, we're
a team of 15 and growing
people, actually, I think we're now at 16.
It started off as, essentially,
it got most know for
video library that I
originally made for my cousins,
put them on YouTube, got
really popular. I was
doing it as a hobby
really, I had a day job as
an analysis at an investment
fund. I was also working
on a primitive version
of software to quiz them
and things like that.
Then in 2009 I quit my job
to work on it full time.
2010 we got funding to
work on it. Most of the
funding is actually to work
on the software platform.
The software lets students
start at any place 1
plus 1 equals 2. It will
generate problems for them.
It'll allow them to move ahead
as they gain proficiency
as they gain mastery
of subjects. They learn at
their own pace. They make
sure that all of the gaps
are filled. The videos
are there to compliment
the exercise platform.
Right now there's over
2,700 videos covering
everything from basic
mathematics to calculus
to college level differential
equations in your algebra,
and sciences, biology,
chemistry, and a little bit
of history, economics, and finance.
The exercises are deeper
K through 12 math.
Over the next year,
hopefully, we'll all see it
get to fairly deep K through,
I would say, 14 math,
so cover all the advanced
mathematics. Then beyond
that we're going to see
the exercise platform move
into physics, chemistry,
and even parts of biology,
and maybe grammar, and things like that.
The whole idea for us as
not for profit, is to be ...
1. For anyone. Anyone to get an education.
Our mission to going to be
a world class education.
Anyone, anywhere for free. Free education.
2. Is to be a tool that
can be levered inside
the classroom to make the
classroom more interactive.
Tool to make the classroom
more interactive.
Classroom interactive. When
I say his, it's a little
intuitive, because we
are a technology tool,
and we involve on demand
video. We involve exercises
that are done on the
computer. How are we making
it more interactive? When
I say more interactive,
I literally mean interactive with humans.
In the model we're experimenting with now,
and the initial results
seem very very promising
in the real classrooms
that we've been dealing
with. So much of the
scaffolding of knowledge,
the conceptional
development, so much of the
exercises can be done
on the online platform.
What we're saying is take
that part out side of
the classroom experience.
This can be done at
a students pace at their
time. Give that data
to the teacher, and so
when the student goes into
the classroom you have
all this freed up time
so the students can teach
each other. Their all
learning at different
paces, and the teacher can
do more focus more deep
interventions with the students.
The teachers now have all of this data.
It frees up time, and powers
the teacher with data.
All of class time no
longer one pace fits all,
one size fits all lectures,
its all about everyone
working at their own pace.
Every minute of a teachers
time and every minute of
a students time is either,
working at their own pace or
interacting with each other.
That's what we talk about
it as a tool. Right now
most of the users are right
over here. Most of the
users are right over here.
We have about 2 1/2 million
unique students a month, and that
numbers growing exponentially really.
They've already watched
over 70 million videos,
and they've done over
100 million exercises.
We have about a million
exercises done per day now.
That number is also
growing rapidly. That's
kind of the general overview
of what we're doing.
One thing I want to be
clear here is for both of
these, we've only had
funding for about 12 months.
I've been doing this
one form or another for
5 or 6 years now, or
actually closer to 7 years.
As an organization we've only
been around for less that a year.
These are works in progress.
We are all ready seeing
good results and good traction
with what we all ready
have. We hope to learn
more and more from the
schools and the teachers and the parents
and the students that we're
working with. To just improve
them better and better and
make this part, make the
education, the classroom, more
and more rich experiences.
Either through things we
do directly, or through
the things that we enable
because we're taking
other things off the table.
Question number 2. What
do you see as the greatest
barrier technological,
cultural, or political to
mainstreaming the Khan Academy
system into public education?
I think the first is
something that I'll put firmly
on Khan Academy shoulders,
on our shoulders, is that,
we have to make a very compelling case.
A compelling case isn't just
a cool piece of software
that a lot of people are
using, or a bunch of videos
a lot of people are
using, that's part of it.
We do have traction. That
traction happened organically,
which I think does speak
to it. No one forces
these 2 million or 2 1/2
million students every
month to use our sight.
They, themselves, find it
compelling. That by itself
isn't enough. We need
to go into classrooms,
and I think it's very
important that people
understand that we don't
think we have a perfective
solution. We think we
have the start of a
compelling solution. What we
want to do is work with,
and this is what we are
doing with our pilot
classrooms. We want to work
with these teachers, students,
parents to make a better
product and see how this
product can be used,
to see how we can make
the classroom as human
of an experience as possible.
Then, of course, we have
to prove that it works.
Proving that it works,
you know, there is one
metric that people, the
education, or maybe the
policy world like, which
is performance on test
scores. We definitely
want to make sure that we
have improvements or at
minimum know negatives.
So far, it does like we are
seeing dramatic improvement
in certain classes using
the model [advocate] and
using these tools.
Improvement also happens in
intangible ways. If now
kids are able to as good
on the test as they were
before or even better
on the test, but now they
have a better attitude
towards mathematics. Their
more attentive in class.
Their able to be exposed.
You have all this
freed up class time to
projects and experiences
that they wouldn't
otherwise been exposed to
that can't necessarily be
captured on an assessment exam.
If those things are
happening, we also view that
as signs of success. These
are things that we have
to prove. Once we do and
hopefully we are able
to prove all of those
things, and it seems like
we are on track, hopefully, knock on wood
to do those things. The next
thing is to really just ...
we are a free solution.
We are not for profit.
People know that we
aren't doing this to make
money off of it, we're doing
this because we generaly
care about education. I think
people want to understand
what we are talking about.
Right now there's some
[knee jerk] reactions
that thinks were all about
kids spending all of
their time on a computer,
spending all of their time watching videos
that somehow replace
teachers. We're about the
opposite of that. We
think class time should be
about interaction. We
think we are the catalysis
to take lectures out of
the classroom, to make the
classroom more interactive.
People have to get over
those [knee jerk] reactions,
which I think aren't
correct perceptions of
what we're trying to do.
Then beyond that is just
a willingness to change.
I think the willingness
to change, there are
many opened minded teachers
that are all ready doing it.
Those are the ones we are working with
to really help define what
we are and help define
what our future should
be. Those are going well,
and I don't know what
percentage of teachers will
fall into that cap, where
they will see a good tool
and like and it seems it has good results.
It gels with their was of
teaching, they'll adopt it.
The last thing I'd want
to see is people being
forced to use Khan Academy.
I really want it to
be something that's opted
into. If you force them
to use even something
that's the best tool on
the planet, and they don't want to use it,
they can make it a not-so-great tool,
and a not-so-great
experience. Our main concern
is really to show that
it's a viable model,
it's a good model. It has
all of the effects that
we want it to have, but
it really is improving
education, both from
assessment point of view
and from a intangible point
of view. We offer it free.
We give as much information
to teachers, policy
makers, and parents so
that their own schools can
adopt it if they want
to. All of our tools are
all ready available for
free, all the tools our
pilots are using. Any
classroom can use today, and
then just see what happens,
I guess is the simple answer.
Next question. Currently,
Khan Academy content
is heavy on subjects that
focus on facts and absolutes,
math, chemistry, physics.
Is that mostly a function
of your background and expertise,
or inheriting the format?
What are the limitations
with your current model
for covering squishy topics
like art, literature,
that are about aesthetics
and interpretation?
I would say it is true we
are covering math, chemistry,
physics, and sometimes their
not as fact or absolute
basis, sometimes people
perceive them to be.
With that said,
I've also started making
videos on history and
economics. Although
economics is often considered
a science, it can be a squishy
subject where aesthetics
and interpenetration do begin to matter.
One thing you will see, and I
think this is very interesting
for the audience for the
future of the museums is,
you will start to see we
are bringing some people
on board in the very near
future on art history.
They've all ready made
some really tremendous
videos, and I will make
the formal announcement
once we have everything
integrated. They've done
a really good job with
art history. They've had
these interesting conversations about it.
I think that's actually
a good model not for just
art history, but it's a good
model for a lot of the humanities.
In something like history
or whatever humanities
you want to pick, it's
nice to have scalpel,
even in art history you
want to have a scalpel.
You want to know what it
means to be a serial painter.
When did the broke period take place?
Or, whatever it might be.
That's where, kind of,
more traditional Khan
Academy style videos are
useful to get you the
scalpel of information.
The conversation type style
which these professors have
kind of pioneered, is
really interesting to get
multiple view points.
Even if they don't cover
all of the multiple view
points, it kind of gives
us the freedom to realize
you can have multiple
view points. They, themselves,
can form their own.
You're going to see a lot more
of that in the near future.
That's on the video side.
On the exercise side,
once again, we can start
to develop exercises that
help. At least make sure
you have the scalpel
of information. You know
where the Civil War fit into
the scope of US History. You
know what the Magna Carta
even was and how it
relates to other documents.
Once you have that
scalpel, you're prepared to
participate in a deeper
discussion in class,
a deeper project, or a deeper
type of simulation in class.
Next question. Can the Khan
Academy model as it currently works
help kids go from learning
facts and operations
to critical reasoning,
or does that require a
different model? I'd actually
say this what we're about.
Right now the problem I
think with a lot of text
books and some classes
is that they are focused
too much on facts and
operations. If you look
at any of the Khan Academy
math videos, sometimes
the facts and operations
are shown, but their
never shown devoid of
the motivation for doing
that fact and operation.
Their never devoid of
the conceptional
understanding. Why it makes
intuitive sense? Why you
can critically deduce
that. You can reason
those facts and operations
just by thinking about the
problem in the right way.
How multiple problems in
different fields actually
reduce to the same core distilled problem.
I actually think that
right now Khan Academy
is all about critical
reasoning. Especially on the
video side. I think on
the exercise there's a lot
more work we have to do,
but we do want to get
there. So, we do expose
students some more simulations,
more projects, more things
that require more than
just knowing the steps
of how to do a problem.
This is, I think, in the
videos we're all ready
doing this to a large
degree. I thinks that's why
Khan Academy videos have
gotten popular. On the
exercises we're starting
with the base scalpel
right now, and right now
the exercise are more
in this direction. I think
over time we're going
to see more and more
exercises that point to
critical reasoning,
simulations, things where
you're going have to
manipulate, kind of virtual
manipulative's to get
to some type of goal.
Next question. 25 years
from now, what do you
think a school day will
be like for an 8-year-old
kid in America? Will she
be commuting to a physical
classroom or accessing
content from home? How will
she study? Who will her
teachers be and what
will be their role? I'll
answer the first question.
Ideally, they will be going
to a physical classroom.
If their in a very rural
place, or they don't
have access, they might
be able to learn accessing
content from home. I think,
we the organization think,
physical interaction with
other people is a huge
part of maturing, and we
hope there's a physical
classroom. We think it
might be a very different
type of physical classroom.
I kind of imagine
every student can work at their own pace.
You don't have to separate
kids by age group anymore.
The benefits of kids
helping each other. I would
imagine one really large
room, or maybe several
really large rooms.
Instead of having 30 kids
in that room, maybe you
have 200 kids in that room.
Obviously, instead of
having 1 teacher, you have
maybe ... 200 kids and
you obviously want to
have as many teachers
as possible. The lower
the student to teacher ratio the better.
Maybe you have ... N
teachers ... if you have
25 to 1 ratio, you would
have 8 teachers here.
You would have 8 teachers
here. I think that's
about consistent with many public schools.
Every student would be
working at their own pace
for some part of the day in every subject.
All the way from grammar
to history to mathematics.
The teachers are there
to mentor them, to guide
them, to help them get
past hurdles. So much of
the learning can hopefully
be done in very efficiently,
most of the day is spent doing projects.
If this is the school day
we want this part course
skills, and the rest
of the day is projects.
The rest of the day is projects.
Kids writing software.
Kids conducting scientific
experiments, real scientific experiments.
Kids producing video content or web pages,
blogs, newspapers, composing music, or
writing short stories.
Whatever it is, their
doing projects, and the
main role of the teachers
will not only be to
help kids get past their
hurdles with the course
skills, so that the kids
can still perform on
these other external exams
and all the rest. Also,
be the mentor for the
projects. We see not just
the teachers being the
mentors for both of
these parts, we see the
students mentoring each
other. If you have kids
of all different age groups
together, then you can
have students who are
more advanced or have an
act for it, to mentor students
who are less advanced,
or who need help in a specific domain.
We like to see the eventual
real powerful transcript.
This is something we
all ready take to heart
when we're hiring people.
It's nice if you went
to a fancy school, with
a fancy GPA, with a fancy
standardized test scores,
but what we really care about
is what have you built
before? What have you
started with a blank
slate? Have you ever put
your ideas into action? Have
you ever built anything?
We think that the resume
of the future will really
be the projects you
work on over the course
of your school years, both
in K through 12 and college.
Frankly, I think that
division between K through 12
and college will also
start to get blurred.
Last question. You've said
your goal is to create
tens of thousands of
videos in pretty much every
subject, and the worlds
first free, world-class
virtual school where
anyone can learn anything.
Can you suggest ways
that museums or museum
practitioners could
contribute to Khan Academy?
I encourage museums or
museum practitioners to both
make content, and I think
some of the art history
content you'll see from us
in the near future, will
give a very good idea
of how to make that type
of content. So, one to
make content and maybe
share it with Khan Academy,
maybe make it part of
the Khan Academy library.
We're hoping to build
tools so that other people
can contribute to the
library in some way. I
think the other possibility
to leverage Khan Academy
material or Khan Academy
like material. If you
have an instillation or
you have a painting on
something, instead of having
a little plaque or next
to the thing that has a
hundred word description
of it, why not have
an explanation of it? Why
not have someone, maybe,
Khan Academy style
explaining what that painting
is all about. Maybe,
using some of our videos
that you're about to see
in the next months on
our history. Why not have
people contribute their own
interpretations of the
art done Khan Academy
style or just an audio
track. I think it lands
itself to a very interesting
question which is
where are museums going?
I think their similar
to schools in that. Before
you had to have a physical
location to have a
school. Similarly you have
to have a physical
location to have a museum.
I think where museums
are going to go is that
their going to turn into these amazing ...
I mean most museums I know of are amazing.
Physical spaces, architectural
spaces, community
spaces, and I think
they'll always be there.
I think they'll always be a
role for those physical spaces.
I think what will happen
is that the content
in those physical spaces
will be much more dynamic.
They won't just be this
insulation that sits
there for 3 months or 6 months or a year.
They'll be information
and installations that
almost change based on
the interactions with
the people who visit the installations.
A lot of that static
content, the paintings,
or the installations, those
can also be virtualized.
If someone goes to the
physical museum that's
obviously the best
experience. If you virtualize
them in the right way, you
can also then bring the
museum experience to
people who don't have the
privilege of going to
museum. I think the Google
art projects starts to
hint at some of this.
If you have the Google
art project, which gives
us very high resolution
pictures of art, that
one can zoom into. You
couple it with kind of
a conversational commentary
on art history or
on the art itself. I think
you start to get close
to that type of experience.